welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and star wars the bad batch has
explored the aftermath of order 66 from
the perspective of clone force 99
and their new kid friend omega opening
up a very cool possible
link between this show and the
mandalorian the prequels the other
animated series
and some new clues revealed by ewan
mcgregor about the upcoming obi-wan
kenobi series
that hopefully we can trust more than we
can trust paul bettany
now in episode three spoiler warning
crosshair goes
way to the dark side leading a squad of
non-clothes as part of vice admiral
ramparts project war mantle
straight up committing war crimes to
shoot and it sounded like burn alive
civilians with saw gerrera's group
meanwhile hunter and omega chased down
one of those pesky order moon dragons
who snatch their power source
while wrecker worryingly keeps rubbing
his head right where the inhibitor chip
is better get that checked out and then
the kaminoans facing their cloning
operation becoming obsolete bring up
a mysterious next phase but from these
first three episodes
a theory is a bruin about how dave
filoni plans to tie together these
questions we're getting from the show
and some other big loose ends from the
other star wars titles because i gotta
say so far
the bad batch has made a really
concentrated effort to weave
its narrative into some other concurrent
events from the star wars timeline
episode 1 depicts old 66 a timeline of
events we saw unfold in revenge of the
sith and then more recently in clone
wars final season last year now we saw
from the point of view of jedi master
depa billaba and her padawan caleb doom
future kanan jairus of star wars rebels
and voiced once again by freddie prince
jr despite the character being like 14
here i'm here the hormones run strong
in this one now deppa and caleb showed
up via holochat in clone wars final
season and we know order 66 is imminent
from
text line clone intelligence is
reporting jedi general obi-wan kenobi
has found and engaged
general grievous on utapau placing this
around the same time as obi-wan's so
uncivilized defeat of grievous and
revenge of the sith
right before commander cody gets the
call and shoots him down
actually this episode even opened with
animated versions of obi-wan anakin
palpatine and grievous from revenge of
the sith
and after hunter lets caleb escape and
they return to camino to find
another mystery jedi dead they
see palpatine's big speech the one from
revenge of the sith maybe even the exact
video feed from that drone camera
[Music]
this series addresses why the empire
shifted from clone troopers to
stormtrooper recruits
tarkin considered camino and clone
troopers too expensive now that the
clone wars have been pretty much won
and he really just needs an occupying
force as he secretly redirects funds to
a more
efficient super weapon we also see some
elements of the mandalorian get their
origins here in the bad patch
like those dark troopers that mop gideon
sends to capture grogu you remember the
ones that luke skywalker slices through
like i will with cheesecake when fitness
origins ends those were version three
dark troopers
and here in the bat batch it looks like
we see some early beta versions that get
unleashed on clone force 99 in that
camino training ground
then episode 2 a bad match deals with
how the empire is now requiring everyone
to carry imperial chain codes and in the
mandalorian boba fett proves his
identity by revealing
his mandalorian chain code detailing the
lineage of his clone father jango fett
now of course all the clone troopers are
clones of jango fett
including these bad batch clones
cutlerqueen who returns in episode 2
and rex whom kutz said had just visited
him on selekamai before the bad batch
arrived
explaining where he went after we last
saw him with sokatano in the clone wars
finale
another django clone includes it would
seem young newcomer omega
named after the final letter of the
greek alphabet as she is supposed to be
the final mutated clone but there seems
to be something more
going on with omega but before we get to
the big thanks to our friends at fetch
rewards for sponsoring this video
fetch rewards offers users free rewards
just by scanning their receipts
the whole process is super easy and only
takes seconds just scan your receipts
from anywhere and you get points and
then you redeem the points and spend
rewards all from your mobile device in a
matter of minutes
there we go i got a receipt from the
post office here here's my scan function
and i'm taking one section at a time
here
and then i submit and then it's
uploading and i get points points points
points points i mean really you can scan
receipts from anywhere grocery stores
restaurants pharmacies you can even scan
e-receipts from online purchases from
sites like amazon and then you can use
the points you earn for all kinds of
gift cards including amazon target
dominoes or dunkin donuts you know what
tastes better than a dunkin apple
fritter a freedom caleb and fritter you
got with your fetch gift card the app
is easy to use easy to sign up easy to
scan the receipts and easy to save
download the app now and use the code
new rockstars to get 3
000 points when you scan your first
receipt this is a limited time offer for
our viewers so act now
download fetch and use the code new
rockstars to get 3 000 points when you
scan your first receipt
omega's kamino and mentor nala say
allowed her in the batch to escape
leading to this mysterious exchange with
camino prime minister
lama su the remaining clones of squad 99
have escaped
along with omega we must be cautious
until the empire's intentions are made
clear
say nothing now he's referring to
tarkin's real reasons for wanting to
phase out the clones the dark star
but what deeper importance does omega
have to the coming owens that they want
to
keep from the empire for now well one
theory many are claiming is that omega
might be
a force sensitive clone maybe an early
attempt in palpatine's cloning efforts
omega does have some surprisingly
accurate aim when she shoots the rifle
out of crosshairs hands
and seems to be able to read his
feelings back in the brig
i know it's not your fault
you can't help it though i don't know if
that qualifies as force sensitivity
necessarily like i read it more as
we need to give this character some
degree of complexity and skill otherwise
she's just gonna be annoying as [ __ ]
really omega just seems really skilled
at picking up and mirroring other clones
talents
like how in this episode she becomes
pretty good at tracking just by watching
and following hunter some are
hilariously comparing omega's hair to
palpatine's do back in phantom minutes
or theorizing that she could be rey's
mother but if
rey's mom would also be a palpatine
strand cast clone like rey's dad was
that would be
pretty interesting stop looking at each
other like that
my clones yuck some are even theorizing
that as a female she could be a clone of
jango fett's sister
arlifet i mean maybe the show will make
omega yet
another seemingly random character
actually part of some hugely famous
bloodline but really i think the most
important aspect of omega was her
function
on kamino as a medical assistant
whatever medical
secrets the kaminoans might have been
hiding omega would have been there for
all of it which brings us to the
interesting chat between lamazu and nala
say in episode three we must
ensure our clones remain essential the
original genetic material
from django fat continues to degrade if
your experiment can yield a superior
clone
it will secure our relationship with
this empire
the clones required will not return
willingly and we only
need one so a superior clone made from
genetic material
separate from that of jango fett now i
assume they are not referring to the bad
batch clones because they wouldn't need
them if they have crosshair right the
implication is that omega is part of
this superior clone program
to produce a clone who can quickly learn
and repeat
unique skills of others which would be a
premium service that the kaminoans hope
would keep them of value to the empire
but go with me on this i think it's
possible that omega isn't the only star
wars character we've seen who's part of
this secret project
because some similar mysteries have also
been hinted at on the mandalorian
in season one dr pershing the scientist
who tried to extract dna from grogu
wore a kamino patch in season two two
officers
also wore that same patch guarding tanks
that appear to contain early versions of
snoke which rises skywalker confirmed
was part of palpatine's strand cast
force sensitive clone effort so
something must have happened on kamino
that dave filoni across
these shows is interested in exploring
and i think
it could be connected to the person star
wars has now decided is the most
marketable face
grogu now kuhil said that this child did
not look engineered and i don't think
grogu is like a clone of yoda or
anything well it might be i just don't
think so but it is possible that this
very special child could have been
brought
to kamino for genetic testing by someone
like sifo diaz
the jedi that hatched that whole deal
with the camino ends to begin with now
timeline wise grogu is actually the same
age as
anakin about 10 years older or so than
omega is
so if omega was around the same time he
was he would have been even more a
newborn but if grogu had ever visited
kamino and if kamino was aware of grogu
that would be
a secret that camino would desperately
want to keep from an empire that just
massacred all the jedi a secret that a
jedi on camino might have died
to keep the empire from discovering now
the little we know about grogu's origin
was told to us by ahogitano
he was raised at the jedi temple on
coruscant many masters trained him over
the years
at the end of the clone wars when the
empire rose to power he was hidden
someone took him from the temple that
mystery savior must have been a jedi
master who knew about grogu while others
like ahsoka didn't who was
alive and present at the jedi temple
during order 66 or shortly after and in
the past i've deduced that savior could
have been yoda obi-wan
yaddle jocasta new or mace windu if he
survived maybe one of them even using
r2d2 to tote the child that is if you
read too much into r2 and grow goo's
little greeting there but
obi-wan emerges now as an interesting
option as someone bad batch episode 1
made sure to check in with
and a character getting his own
live-action series very soon ewan
mcgregor just revealed a mysterious
cameo is coming in that show
i got to play a very special scene on
may the 4th someone very special in my
life
and uh uh that's how that's all i can
tell you about it is this someone
special that we've seen you on camera
with before
no is this special person related to you
in some way no not necessarily
damn it you win paul benton he already
screwed with us by saying the luke
skywalker level cameo is coming to wanna
vision just for it to be his even pace
yourself don't you hurt us too
but ewing has also said he was raised
not to lie so if we take him at his word
that would rule out people that he had
shared the screen with in the prequels
like liam neeson
frank oz as yoda samuel l jackson or
someone who's related to like
one of his kids but someone very special
in his life someone special in all of
our lives
is grogu we could see the flashback of
obi-wan with grogu either when he helped
the kid escape or when he was a part of
grogu's passage from hands to hands and
i bring all this up with omega in the
bad match because
i believe omega as a camino medical
assistant
was really part of a superior clone
program
where genetic material is harvested from
young gifted donors like omega and yeah
maybe like grogu all to engineer
superior specimens for
dark purposes support this channel by
checking out our merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
to new rockstars and breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you